hablamos mucho sobre las nuevas
generaciones las criticamos parece que
nos incomoda que no vivan la vida como
nosotros creemos que la tienen que vivir
que no prioricen y que no valoren como
nosotros pensamos que deberían valorar
y esto es clave para entender por qué la
educación y la visión de los padres de
familia está llena de preocupaciones a
mí lo que más me preocupa de las nuevas
generaciones son sus papás porque porque
las tendencias generacionales vienen de
casa vienen de la educación y la gran
pregunta que yo me hago es como son los
papás de las nuevas generaciones y esa
es la inquietud que me trae aquí con
ustedes primero somos la primera
generación de papás conectada a las
redes sociales de entrada esto nos hace
un poco ansiosos y un poco nerviosos
porque ahora nos enteramos de todo lo
malo que le puede pasar a nuestros hijos
en segundo lugar compartimos mucha
información a veces muy sesgada pero
constantemente estamos intercambiando
ideas sobre cómo ser buenos papás
retratamos en cada publicación
relacionada con nuestros hijos como
creemos que nosotros somos buenos padres
y creo que hay puntos favorables aquí
porque en general somos una generación
de papás interesados en optar por un
estilo parental amigable
tres ideas compartimos mucho sobre
paternidad maternidad en redes sociales
primero sea amoroso con tus hijos dos se
cerca no dedicarles tiempo 3 asegúrate
de que crezcan felices ahora imagínense
que tomamos estas ideas las llevamos a
un extremo y las distorsionamos sobre
eso te voy a poner algunos ejemplos
cuando tus hijos llegan a la edad
escolar una nueva red social va a
influir en tu relación con ellos se
llama grupo de whatsapp de papás los
chats de papás no sé si los conocen si
han tenido contacto con alguno de ellos
son muy bonitos son bellos porque
básicamente es una pequeña comunidad de
padres de familia que aman muchísimo a
sus hijos y están completamente
dispuestos a ayudarles el problema es
que muchas veces ayudarles significa
hacerles la tarea de la escuela
y esto comienza en el preescolar que
tarea le dejas a un pequeñito de
preescolar que tome con sus manos un
bodoque de plastilina que lo unte en una
tabla que a eso le llamamos maqueta y no
importa como lo entregue va a estar bien
porque sus habilidades apenas se están
despertando y queremos que se sienta
bien con ellos
pero esas no son las tareas que llegan a
los preescolares llegan maquetas con un
trazo arquitectónico perfecto
electrificadas hechas a escala ni
leonardo da vinci a los cinco años
hubiera hecho trabajos tan magníficos en
la primaria el asunto es más marcado
todavía actualmente estoy en 18 grupos
de whatsapp de papás y no es porque
tengo 18 hijos
es porque esto es un proceso de
investigación colaboro con algunas
instituciones educativas para encontrar
patrones hallazgos cómo se comportan
estas comunidades digitales de padres de
familia bien hay un patrón de
comportamiento que está presente en los
18 grupos por igual los 18 funcionan
igual y todo comienza cuando alguien
hace la gran pregunta de un grupo de
whatsapp de papás que es alguien sabe
que hay de tarea
y después de eso llega a toda una
avalancha de respuestas e
interpretaciones porque nadie sabe nunca
qué hay de tarea la tarea ya no es
resultado de la comunicación de la
maestra con los niños la tarea es la
meta interpretación el meta-análisis que
hacen los papás en el grupo de whatsapp
con interpretaciones de todo tipo es
algo sobre dinosaurios es algo sobre el
precámbrico es algo sobre el jurásico
sobre el jurídico que importa amén mi
hijo me dijo que era la biografía de
godzilla
hasta que llega un momento clave y es
cuando alguien sube una tarea ya hecha
pues miren nosotros así lo entendimos y
así lo hicimos y regularmente es una
tarea muy bien hecha se ve bonita si no
no la subirían y esto pone nerviosos a
todos los papás porque dicen a mi hijo
no le va a quedar así
tengo que ayudarle y en el afán de
ayudarles
los papás terminan haciendo toda la
tarea mientras los niños están en una
pantalla viendo a [ __ ] pig
en mis tiempos me tocó hacer a mí de una
generación a la que nos daban la boleta
de calificaciones y a veces con cierto
miedo tenemos que llevarla a nuestros
papás quizá haciendo una reverencia de
perdón porque volvimos a reprobar
matemáticas
ellos la tenían que firmar y nosotros
devolvemos la boleta firmada como
evidencia de que ellos habían visto y
más de alguno más de alguno en más de
alguna ocasión se atrevió a evitar ese
momento y falsificó la firma de sus
papás para entregar la boleta sin que
ellos se dieran cuenta
y lo que hoy se ve es que hoy son los
papás los que falsifican la letra de sus
hijos
para que la maestra no se dé cuenta de
que ellos hicieron la tarea
pasamos a la secundaria en la secundaria
los grupos de whatsapp de papas son como
la reina de corazones de alicia las
fricciones con los maestros son mayores
y son normales porque es la adolescencia
entonces hay más relaciones conflictivas
entre maestros y alumnos es normal pero
muchas veces los papás no lo entienden y
siempre toman partido por sus hijos
creen que han sido agredidos y se
preguntan constantemente quién es esa
maestra la que se enojó la que los
castigó la que los regaño la que les
dejó mucha tarea que le corten la cabeza
son tensos los grupos de whatsapp de
papás de secundaria en ese sentido y
damos el salto hasta la universidad ya
no hay grupos de whatsapp de mapas en la
universidad inicial les ocurra hacerlo
sería un desastre
pero en la universidad vemos otros
fenómenos sobre este estilo parental tan
cercano antes lo normal era ver a los
chicos
ir solos inscribirse a la universidad
hoy lo más común es ver a los papás
inscribiendo a sus hijos en la
universidad y a veces llegan sin los
hijos a pedir los trámites los informes
sobre la beca a preguntar sobre las
carreras casi casi a elegir la carrera y
sólo falta que quieren hacer el examen
de admisión ellos
ahora
en todo este rango de tiempo desde
preescolar hasta la universidad se ha
observado el fenómeno era inevitable que
llegara a la vida laboral y si desde
hace algunos años
se ve padres de familia yendo a los
lugares de empleo a las empresas a las
organizaciones a preguntar sobre los
puestos a cuestionar las prestaciones a
entregar el currículum que muchas veces
hacen ellos y hoy es lo más común que en
las oficinas de recursos humanos lleguen
estos correos que dicen este es el
currículum de mi hijo muy amado a quien
recomiendo ampliamente
el extremo de esto y si sucede no digo
que sucede muchísimo pero cada vez
sucede más y en su extremo tenemos
padres de familia que quieren tratan e
intentan estar presentes en la
entrevista de trabajo de sus hijos en
una comunidad
en un grupo de personas profesionales en
recursos humanos tratamos sobre este
tema sobre tendencias de las nuevas
generaciones en la vida profesional y es
inevitable hablar de los padres de
familia y su nueva presencia en el
entorno laboral y un testimonio que me
pareció inolvidable un rh que nos dijo a
mí me pasó me equivoqué y alguna vez sin
permitir que la mamá del candidato
entrara la entrevista llegué y me estaba
esperando la señora estaba ahí y me
abordó usted es el licenciado heredia si
a sus órdenes mire yo soy la mamá de
sant y él viene entrevista con ustedes
me imagino me imagino que sí estaría muy
mal que yo entrara la entrevista verdad
y dijo bueno yo jamás me imaginé que una
situación así pudiera existir resolver
rápido y sin pensar y en el afán de ser
amable le dije no hay problema pase
usted claro que cuando iba dando pasos
hacia la oficina me preguntaba pero qué
demonios estoy haciendo
entonces todos todos escuchamos este
relato con mucha atención le suplicamos
que nos dijera qué pasó adentro de esa
oficina porque parece ser muy
significativo esto esto es un dato
importante es un buen ejemplo de la
llegada de una nueva generación a la
vida profesional y nos dijo pues si
efectivamente la señora respondía muchas
preguntas en lugar del candidato le
complementaba las respuestas
yo le pregunté tienes experiencia o
conocimiento en control de inventarios
pues no sé creo que no que es un
inventario
acuérdate que eso fue lo que hiciste en
la fábrica de tu tío lo que pasa es que
tengo un cuñado que tiene una pequeña
fábrica y santi trabajo con él un verano
no sabe usted le controló todos los
inventarios mi cuñado quedó contentísimo
con su desempeño
gracias señora candidato rechazado
bien fíjense cómo hemos distorsionado
tres buenas ideas se amoroso con tus
hijos se ha convertido en que no
experimenten emociones negativas
se cercano se ha convertido en
embarra té en sus asuntos vinculante en
todo y resuelve
que crezcan felices y es raro como
entendemos la felicidad de nuestros
hijos hoy parece que hoy la felicidad de
nuestros hijos muchos papás la entienden
como que no tengan problemas reducir al
mínimo los problemas y reducir al mínimo
las emociones negativas y eso es
debilitar los
así es como hemos distorsionado esta
voluntad auténtica que tenemos de ser
buenos padres porque la voluntad de
césar
pero podemos llevar al extremo nuestras
creencias sobre en qué consiste eso y
cómo se logra eso
entonces me quiero dirigir a los jóvenes
como ven la situación ustedes qué les
parece
así están tus papás no necesariamente
todos no podemos generalizar es obvio
que no todos los padres de familia son
así pero la tendencia así es muy visible
es muy marcada en las instituciones
educativas en la universidad y bueno
esto qué pasa en la vida laboral se nota
y en esta distorsión de ideas resulta
que hay cosas que tus papás dejan de
observar sobre ti hay cosas que tus
papás no saben de ti cuáles son primero
que ya creciste los papás somos los
últimos en enterarnos de que nuestros
hijos ya crecieron no nos gusta nos
incomoda y más aún cuando recibimos esa
notificación de facebook que dice que
hoy se cumplen años de aquella vez que
te disfrazaste de cebollita y bailas te
en el festival de la escuela
2 tus papás no saben de ti que tú ya
eres una persona totalmente responsable
totalmente capaz de resolver muchas
cosas que siguen resolviendo ellos
y tampoco saben que cuando ellos
resuelven esos asuntos que ya deberías
resolver tú te están enviando
accidentalmente involuntariamente pero
te están enviando un mensaje que dice no
creo que tú seas capaz de hacerlo y hoy
voy a llegar a la vida profesional a
muchos jóvenes inseguros temerosos
solamente certeros de algo me voy a
equivocar tienen este mensaje bien
clavado en la cabeza sus papas tampoco
saben de ti que cuando van a la escuela
y conspiran para que corran a todos los
profesores difíciles sangrones exigentes
y estrictos te están quitando a ti la
oportunidad
de aprender algo que es importante en la
vida tratar con gente difícil porque te
vas a encontrar muchísima
los maestros exigentes son los que te
entrenan para ello
algo que se repite mucho en las críticas
que se hacen a las nuevas generaciones
son vulnerables son frágiles en sus
emociones pareciera que se toman como
ofensa lo que en realidad no es ofensa
necesitas más profesores estrictos como
estos que te cierran la puerta de la
clase a la hora en punto y ya no te
dejan entrar más
te vas a cortar de ellos en un
aeropuerto
después de haber perdido un vuelo y los
vas a recordar con mucho cariño dejen
que los profesores estrictos sean así
aunque ya no sé si ahí creo que ya los
metieron a la cárcel a todos
sus papás tampoco saben que cuando van a
la escuela y hablan con la maestra con
la directora te quitan a ti la
oportunidad de aprender a negociar otra
paquete de competencias en los que la
nueva generación suele tener déficit
aprender a negociar habilidades de
conversación de persuasión etcétera
y es que tú tienes que arreglar tus
propios asuntos es cierto la maestra se
equivocó con tu calificación pues tu
habla con ella expone la situación a la
maestra no te hizo caso entonces tuve
hablar con la directora claro que puedes
hacerlo ve y hazlo tú esto es empoderar
tus hijos cuando vas tú a resolver el
asunto haces todo lo contrario de
empoderar los los debilita si los
conviertes en víctimas potenciales a las
que hay que cuidar muchísimo porque
pueden sufrir
jóvenes ustedes pueden ayudar mucho a
darle la vuelta a esta situación sus
padres tienen las mejores intenciones
solo que hay cosas que no son tan
fáciles hoy de darte cuenta antes los
papás le daban la responsabilidad a sus
hijos hoy la responsabilidad lo tienes
que pedir
primero responde esta pregunta cuántas
cosas que ya podría resolver tú siguen
resolviendo tus papás
segundo
como podrías hacerle saber que tú ya
eres capaz de resolver déjenme hacerlo
yo hay que decirlo con todo el cariño
déjenme hacerme responsable déjenme
tomar este asunto en mis manos quizás
nos va a asustar un poco porque se van a
dar cuenta de que ya creciste de que ya
tienes capacidad de ser responsable y
eso da miedo saben por qué porque crecer
es muy peligroso crecer se trata de
enfrentar la vida con todas sus
dificultades
con buena actitud crecer se trata de
vivir y por si no lo saben vivir es la
principal causa de muerte
para los papás tengo un mensaje
importante dejen que sus hijos vivan sus
problemas en particular las emociones
negativas que están asociadas a estos no
se trata de abandonarlos y dejarlos
bueno pues que se las arregle el no vas
a acompañar vas a orientar vas a guiar
pero no les resuelvas lo que ellos ya
pueden resolver
y si se sienten frustrados qué bueno
señal de que algo les importa
acompáñanos a resolver la frustración
pero no les evite es la frustración
tengo la esperanza de que a través de
télex este mensaje llegue a muchos
padres de familia e hijos para que
juntos operen este sencillo pero
poderoso cambio de mentalidad sé que va
a ser de un impacto muy positivo en el
futuro de muchos niños y jóvenes para
que se conviertan en personas capaces de
generar su propia felicidad y yo ya me
voy porque mi hija tiene mucha tarea
para mañana y yo tengo que ayudarla
gracias
[Aplausos]